I don't think there's much to celebrate
we are paralyzed in Parliament not just
within the Conservative Party but
generally because the realization is
dawning that there is no form of brexit
which is going to be of advantage to our
country now the only people who think
that's not the case are some of my AG
colleagues which is why they willing to
contemplate a No Deal brexit but there's
a vast majority of members of parliament
who think a No Deal brexit would be
disastrous for us and as a consequence I
there's no doubt that things are getting
more tense and we've got to try to find
a way through this crisis in my view the
Prime Minister should be doing two
things you should be firstly seeking the
extension to article 50 because we're
clearly going to need more time to
debate options and secondly something
I've long believed I think we're going
to have to go back to the public and ask
the public what it is they want we can
offer them some forms of brexit they may
not be forms of brexit that I want but
nevertheless if that is what they want
we can give it to them equally if people
wish to change their views and wish to
remain in the EU it is still possible to
do that and I think we should be
thinking very carefully along those
lines if you want to find a way through
this do you think it is likely that
there could be a second referendum
because it seems as though it's less
likely than ever and a lot of people
saying you know what it may just
continue to drag this out this period of
uncertainty
I disagree I think the possibility of a
second referendum has always been there
it's apparently Labour Party policy but
it would be nice of Jeremy Corbyn were
to actually speak out for one rather
than prevaricated over it and it offers
a potential solution none of the other
things a moment appear to offer a
solution at all and that's what troubles
me clearly if there was a coming
together at the House of Commons around
a particular form of brexit then we can
exit on that particular form but
everything I've seen in the last few
months suggests that four perfectly
valid reasons opinion in the house is
deeply divided because most MPs look at
brexit and see that in fact leaving is
going to be greatly to our disadvantage
so to agree something which you know is
going to do the country damage is very
difficult as I say my ERG colleagues are
the exception to that they are
enthusiastic about leaving and they
appear to be entirely untroubled about
all the potential consequences that most
people believe will flow from No Deal
departure which I think will be chaos
and real damage to our country's
economic future and well-being and I'm
just not prepared to go there under any
circumstances I mean we've just had one
of your ERG colleagues on the programme
it's a burner Jenkins and he said that
this is actually down to the fact that
three-quarters of MPs have always been
remainders remain remain as and just
can't get over the results of the
referendum that that is a perfectly
reasonable comment but what he is asking
those three quarters of MPs to do is to
abandon their conscience their judgment
and their views and to sign up to
something which they believe will be
disastrous for their constituents it's
just not going to happen
and yet whilst all this arguing is going
on and it seems as you say to coin a
phrase we're struggling to square a
circle it looks doesn't it as though No
Deal is becoming increasingly likely 42
days to go and that's very clearly in
our sights now
but that's why I think the Prime
Minister should be taking steps to
extend the article 50 period now there's
an opportunity for her to do this but if
she doesn't do it then as was explained
by my colleagues Oliver let win yes in
the debate yesterday the House of
Commons is going to have to take action
to try to ensure that an extension can
be secured because so many of us take
the view that leaving without a deal
would be uniquely damaging to our
country and is there any deal that you
would accept I mean how would you feel
about being part of this customs union
as Jeremy Corbyn has said you know could
you tolerate that or would you see that
as a sort of soft brexit and therefore
pointless as Tony Blair has argued there
are a series of possible ways in which
we could leave the EU but I have to say
I've also taken the fundamental view a
long time ago that they should be put to
the electorate one of the problems we
have is that the debate we had in 2016
there's very little relationship to the
realities that we are now facing and
it's the fact that that's the case which
makes me so clear in my mind that we
should go back and ask the public if the
public want to leave on a Norway basis
if they want to leave on the Prime
Minister's deal which may well be the
best deal on offer and the only deal
then so be it
I will accept it but to sign something
off which has become increasingly clear
is going to do our country harm
difficult as a matter of conscience for
any member of parliament to do such a
thing